in this video we will be showcasing to
you all the 10 largest leviathans taken
from movies
games and other fictional work as we all
know leviathans are large gigantic
creatures but
how do we know that well mostly from
these games movies and shows
so check this video out number 10 homo
aquaticus
homo aquaticus is the main antagonist of
the 1989
italian-american horror film leviathan a
strange aquatic creature created by the
mutagenic chemicals made by the russians
its goal is to assimilate the crew
members of an underwater mind
supervision team
its appearance varies throughout the
film due to its dna absorption abilities
but its final appearance at the film's
climax is a large
black and tan gilman-like creature
covered in scales
its protruding lower jaw is armed with
numerous teeth and on the creature's
hunched back
is a human head and there is also a
human arm emerging from its side
it is the smallest leviathan at only 10
to 20 feet in size
number nine coming from the game dead
space the leviathan was a massive
amorphous necromorph
encountered in the usg ishimura's foot
storage facility during an outbreak
aboard the vessel it is stated that
within the game the leviathan was
drifting in space until it collided with
the ishimura
if that is so then the leviathan
obviously couldn't have been
formed from any of the crew members like
the other monsters in the game
but it is entirely a new alien organism
the leviathan
is immobile and attacks by outstretching
its large tentacles to slam into
the protagonist isaac and crushing him
from a gaping orifice in its center the
beast launches large
organic projectiles that detonate on
impact this creature is easily a hundred
to two hundred feet in size
ten times the previous one number eight
leviathan from the resistance this
monstrous by peterland walking leviathan
comes from the game resistance and it is
one of the chimera species
what are the chimera species well the
chimera species are an alien species
that previously inhabited earth in
millions of years
prior to humanity's existence until they
were forced to leave the planet
following a devastating conflict with
another alien race
the leviathan is a 300 foot tall chimera
and only two leviathans were ever
reported in the game
described as the single largest creature
to ever have walked the earth
these bipedal creatures possess large
cooling devices on their back
as well as skin that repels all kind of
weaponry
with the exception of explosives the
origins of the leviathan is only known
in the final campaign
level burning skies number seven
leviathan from avengers
leviathans are colossal beasts used as
weapons and troop transports during the
invasion of earth
by the chittori alien species while
their history and how they came to be
used by the chitauri is unknown
they were notably involved in an attack
on earth by loki
initially one was brought through a
dimensional rift over manhattan
and caused a significant amount of
destruction before being beaten by the
hulk and iron man
a five mode were beaten by further
actions of the avengers before loki's
portal was closed
despite their massive bulk the
leviathans were able to offset the
effect of gravity and fly through
unknown means
they appear to use a series of fins to
aid them in steering and move through
the air in a sedation or a way like
fashion they are also around 300 feet
long
number six the sea dragon leviathan from
subnautica
so there will be two entries from the
games of nordica owing to the vast
number of different types of leviathans
which we might just cover in another
video all by itself
the sea dragon leviathan is a colossal
leviathan-class foreigner species
it is the largest aggressive creature of
subnautica the sea dragon leviathan's
body
mostly resembles the sea emperor
leviathan which is a bigger species
and albeit much smaller and slimmer in
design
the body is mostly dark green in color
along with
purple accents on the web limbs and head
it has a protective plate on the other
side of its body
that starts at the neck and run down
where the tentacles begin
this creature is 112 meters or 367 feet
long
number five the sea emperor leviathan
from subnautica
the next entry from subnautica is the
sea empire leviathan itself
and it is the largest of the living
leviathan's class fauna of subnautica
it is sentient and telephotic the sea
emperor leviathan is colossal having a
stocky entirely armored body
and is predominantly pale brown in color
with shades of green
its tentacles are down with bright cyan
bioluminescent bulbs
the sea emperor leviathan's posterior
consists of seven long
yet slim tentacles ending with large
tentacular
clubs with the largest being in the
center surrounded by the six smaller
tentacles
despite its gargantuan size the sea
emperor leviathan's diet consists of
solely of microorganisms
and just like berlin whales this
creature is 200 meters or 656 feet long
and also 2 600 years old
number 4 the leviathan from mars effect
the leviathans from mars effect are an
ancient aquatic race that dominated the
galaxy in the time before the reapers
they regard themselves as the galaxy's
first and only
apex race and think of other races as
mere tools
which are meant to serve them with the
advent of the reapers the leviathans
were forced into hiding to preserve
themselves
and were content to observe the reaper's
harvest while
syrup seriously erasing any evidence of
their existence over the course of
hundreds of millions of years
like the reapers that were designed
after them the leviathans are massive in
size around 1 kilometers of 3
300 feet and resemble cuttlefish or
squids
number three leviathan from atlantis the
lost empire
seen in the disney film atlantis the
lost empire the leviathan is a giant
atlantean artifact that was left near
the underwater entrance to atlantis
so that it could protect the city the
leviathan is a mechanical monstrosity
that closely resembles a lobster
it is also capable of flight as seen
just before the destruction of atlantis
the sheer immense size of the leviathan
which was capable of holding their 382
foot long
ship called the ulysses within just its
smallest set of claws
allowing it to easily crush its enemies
it can easily destroy enemy ships with
one blow by launching powerful balls of
electrical energy from its mouth
and so by looking at how it holds the
ulysses ship
it will be anywhere between twelve to
fourteen thousand feet
or more than four kilometers in size
number two the leviathan from starcraft
the zerg swarm is a terrifying and
ruthless amalgamation of biologically
advanced
ultraportal species of xenomorphic hyper
evolutionary superorganisms
whew that was a lot they are the
overriding antagonists for much of the
starcraft series of games
the leviathan is a massive airborne and
space-borne zerg breed
the leviathans are zerg's equivalent of
large capital ships
seen in space they are classified as a
class 10 zerg flyer
and are the largest and terran records
larger than the mothership
terrans are humans in the game of those
dwarfed by an arc ship which are
ships of the protoss and other alien
species and have been referred to as
moon
sized so these leviathans as per the
measurements taken by the terran
dominion have placed them
at being around 6.7 kilometers long
and number one scp-169 leviathan
this is one of the largest and most
threatening scps from the universe
of the scp foundation it is a marine
arthropod cross station of enormous size
known as leviathan from generations of
sailors throughout history
unlike the other lethal scp such as 682
or 049 that are contained within the
foundation itself
scp-169 is incapable of being contained
due to its immense size
the beast is estimated to be around two
thousand
and eight thousand kilometers long
scp-169 is also believed to have existed
on earth
since the pre-gambian era so around 500
million years or so
no other specimens have been cited and
almost nothing is known about scp-169's
habits
such as its reproductive capabilities if
any its food source
and nesting area so this brings us to
the end of the list of the 10 largest
leviathans in fiction
so hit that subscribe button and bell
button and like button
and check out our other videos take care
fam